You share a certain percentage of your genome with
each different type of family member in your family
tree. For example, we'll start with you. You are
100% related to you and to every other family member
you're going to be less genetically related unless, of course,
you have an identical twin. Now we've discussed a
few of these relationships. And a few of the
percentages that you would be with each individual family member.
But I want you to see if you can fill in the rest
of this family tree a percentage relationships. Using the options that you see
here in the number bank. Now this could be a little bit tricky,
so take the time to think about each person would relate back to you.